so i've been taking some shots from the
audience about i guess some people in
the audience think i'm too empathetic i
i'm i'm too empathetic when it comes to
people that haven't gotten vaccinated
and then get very sick or sometimes die
yeah i feel bad for those people
if if you want to attack me for being
too empathetic i will take it it doesn't
seem like the worst character flaw to
have uh but i have an example for you
today
of someone who is apparently in a really
bad position
and i don't really feel bad and maybe
now people will be mad that i don't feel
bad but the latest report is that rudy
giuliani is reportedly close to broke
and now donald trump seems to have cut
him off as well there's a very
interesting article in mother jones
which says
having raised more money than anyone
else in the republican party so far this
year new filings show donald trump is
flush with cash now later we'll talk
about what he's doing with some of that
cash and it's very grifty
absolutely swimming in it but even as
the money flows in the former president
is reportedly stiffing one of his
fiercest allies and loyal political
surrogates rudy
giuliani as the former new york mayor
becomes increasingly ensnared in a
federal investigation reportedly costing
him millions in legal fees
here's the latest on the apparent
fallout between the two men maggie
haberman tweeted
giuliani allies are looking at the trump
money even if it is an 82 million and
are aghast that trump isn't helping
giuliani with legal fees
trump doesn't care about anybody when
they are no longer useful to him that's
what's good that's always the case it's
no different with rudy
maggie goes on to tweet giuliani's
friends say he is close to broke
and his interview with melissa russo
makes clear he knows he's in legal
jeopardy
going on to say trump aides have been
clear they see no mechanism for paying
rudy's legal bills that isn't
problematic for trump and they think
giuliani took actions as a lawyer
should have known were problematic
strange phrasing but i understand what
it says even if the client wanted it
that's particularly worrisome for
giuliani whose legal defense fund has
effectively failed to raise anything in
his fight against the federal probe into
whether he worked as an unregistered
lobbyist for ukrainian officials
giuliani who was recently suspended from
practicing law in new york is also
facing a separate lawsuit from dominion
voting systems over his relentless
election lies and despite his penchant
for conspiracy theories and
misinformation it appears as haberman
notes that giuliani does seem to
understand the gravity of his precarious
legal situation
so
this is a disaster for rudy
but it is really a deserved one quite
frankly i mean you know that this guy's
an adult
he was a competent lawyer he didn't so
much fall for something as he made some
kind of calculation
that he was going to get involved and
defend everything trump does no matter
what and even go above and beyond eat
not just while trump was trying to be
re-elected trump loses and then rudy
becomes the front person the most
prominent person going around the
country spreading covid
and also spreading bogus uh hypotheses
about how trump actually won
he turned himself into a pawn
for a psychopathic
narcissistic egomaniac that was donald
trump
how else was this ultimately going to
end and a little bit later we're going
to talk about new reports that donald
trump has been funneling the grifted 80
million or 72 million or whatever he
raised over the last few months to fight
the election results he's been funneling
it into his own businesses but he's not
going to pay rudy giuliani's legal fees
so what options does rudy have close to
broke a couple things that come to mind
one i don't know if you remember but
there was there were a few instances
where rudy mentioned that he has an
insurance policy
he said that he has this insurance
policy which is some kind of evidence
of trump wrongdoing and that if he were
to have a problem with trump he would
have this evidence of some kind as an
insurance policy
did he really have that we don't know
did he have it but maybe it's not really
a value anymore because it's part of
what was seized when his home and office
were raided by federal authorities a
month or two ago
we don't know is rudy going to have to
flip
although then it actually raises
questions you know it's it's really it's
complicated because rudy was trump's
lawyer but he was really only like his
tv lawyer
until after the election rudy actually
started filing motions in courts but
then trump's sort of distance and it's
not clear whether that was really a
representation the point is
if rudy were to think about flipping and
i don't know that he's thinking of that
but if he were
is there a question of attorney-client
privilege somewhere in there i don't
know i don't know but it shouldn't shock
any of us
that
rudy didn't end up getting 20 million a
day
from trump who notoriously stiffs
everybody that works for him so rudy is
in a bad place
i you know it's
it's hard for me not to feel a little
bad the guy's nearly 80
he may be broke
i feel a little bad i do
but this is really of his own doing it's
not even like rudy you know an anti-vaxx
person who's the victim of
disinformation propaganda all around
them they go to work and it's anti-vaxx
propaganda they go on facebook it's
anti-vaxx propaganda then they get sick
with kovid
i see them really as as mostly victims
although they are also perpetrators by
continuing to signal boost the anti-vaxx
propaganda rudy's not really a victim
here rudy rudy's just a lawyer and he
made a bad call he made the wrong
decision and now he's going to have to
apparently pay the price for it
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the subscription streaming service that
offers
thousands of documentaries from the
world's best filmmakers so yes there are
some documentaries on netflix hulu
amazon but none of those streaming
services give you anything close to the
selection of what you get on
curiositystream they have all the newest
and most critically acclaimed
documentary titles i'm always finding
amazing stuff that i can't find anywhere
else i just actually watched engineering
the future and just super interesting
about we really may be on the precipice
here of a total paradigm shift in terms
of what human engineering can do and
they're always adding new stuff on
curiosity stream they have documentaries
on every topic imaginable i can watch on
every device i own and the best part is
that when you go to curiositystream.com
pacman my audience gets 25 off that
makes it 15 for the entire year
that is not a lot of money for the
amount of enjoyment that i know you will
get from curiositystream and the link is
right underneath this video